hi Jim yourself follow cool I called
like three weeks ago and Alla diagnosed
with hypertension hearing loss and
chronic kidney disease with a low output
of about 15% me recently I went to us
you know a second kidney specialist in
her opinion and then they also did a
urine test on me and they found a lot of
protein in my Giri so I have been lately
I have been taking the ultimate classic
the selenium the EF a yeah I'm just you
know I just want reassurance they hang
on here a second here second were you
ever on dialysis no you're not yeah what
do you what do you weigh sir what's that
what do you weight body weight Oh body
weight I weight about 132 okay and sharp
aim okay he's got very good program
there got to get on the diet but what
would you add to it to support a healthy
blood pressure healthy blood flows or
blocked arteries which is you know I
would have the ultimate daily classic
very good you get an A+ deer yep you
need to get to bowels of the ultimate
daily classic take three those twice a
day and let's see here
that's again gonna support healthy blood
pressure healthy but those are blocked
arteries usually when you have protein
in your urine you have some kitty issues
it's usually obstructive arteries you
get plaque in the arteries carrying the
dirty button so the talker uses the
kidneys so the blood will show the
kidneys aren't filtering but it's not a
kidney problem per se it's actually
arteries being plugged and can't get the
dirty budget is poking us in the the
ultimate daily classic will support
healthy blood flows are blocked arteries
and support healthy blood pressure
everything else has charge said no bad
food no fried food no process me so
how's the glutens
and of course hearing loss aboard you do
for his bone health because hearing loss
could be osteoporosis of the skull
squeezing the auditory branch of the HP
on nerve so what would you add
to the two healthy brain and heart packs
what would you add to that and to help
support mains repair of bones and that
kind of stuff he could take some gluco
gel okay guys get two bottles Luka
Chelsea take 15 a day five a breakfast
lunch and dinner and what else would you
do for vitamin d3
hi everyone d3 well there you go you
need to be the capsules take three of
those twice a day the two bottles a
month or the are the citrus vitamin d3
or two spray bottles of those take three
sprays twice a day breakfast and dinner
time and it wouldn't hurt as Shari said
get some of the CM cream and you can put
a quarter of a teaspoon down in each
year with a q-tip like you're trying to
get wax out of your ears and that'll
relieve some of the inflammation around
the roots of the of the age cranial
nerve the branch of course is the
auditory branch we have hearing loss a
gradual hearing loss and it's amazing
how quickly the body can repair itself
including cost you proces of the skull
call us every couple of weeks Johnny and
we'll walk you through this